[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est juste besoin que tu signe
quelque chose pour Luke je l'ai envoyé toujours faire
le mannequinat il adore ça il est passionné
par ça je ne devrais pas faire du mannequinat
tu n'es pas dans sa vie ça ne t'affecte
pas non  être une douleur dans le but de
votre voyage visiter la famille on dirait que
vous avez été signalé - rien du tout juris
époque je suis pratique très célèbre danse
bien en France ouais
hmm ce que je ne sais pas il n'est juste pas là
exactement je te vois  J'étais l'assistant de
David Spade, en
fait, j'ai
suivi l'assistant de David Spade et si vous le suivez
jusqu'en bas, il est écrit ombre ouais, mais
ils ont tous les astéroïdes, alors oui, vous
voyez, sérieusement, vous êtes venu ici,
je veux remplir mes devoirs de père,
je '  suis l'un des modèles et vous êtes mr.
Alan Ross non mais je suis son père
biologiquement mais l'homme que je considère comme mon
vrai père ne pourrait pas être ici juste
Nolan Ross n'es-tu pas populaire et comme
Francis ouais ça n'a pas d'importance
parce que ce n'est pas les États-Unis  exactement vous
savez que c'est tout j'en ai fini avec la comédie je m'en
suis éloigné bien
alors hé la comédie nous ne faisons pas beaucoup de
comédie dans la maison c'est une
période sérieuse dans le monde ces jours-ci il n'y a pas
beaucoup de rires d'amis de chambre je  je ne peux pas laisser
Jason Allen Ross élever mon fils il
vénère ce gars Jason il cire des tas de
fois comment puis-je rivaliser tu as ça tu
veux aider à retourner à Paris tu es un
roi là-dedans Dieu jamais trop tard tu
sais que ça dit aussi  un peu trop tard
savez-vous que celui-là c'est légitime c'est
ce mec c'est un chat il est cool n'a pas l'air
cool
quoi ouais il est français
[Musique]
toi